rien sinon je me suis piqué art et 6 ont
tué d'une maladresse incroyable tu
devrais prendre l'exemple sur moi je me
suis pas piquer une seule fois aux bains
évidemment fauqué a pris les
investisseurs avec le bourrant alors tu
ne risques rien les miens sont beaucoup
plus dangereux le tout est de savoir
comment s'y prendre avec désigne toute
part
ça alors c'est bien fait ça t'apprendra
pas se moquer de moi
aussi je me suis rendu
là qu'est ce qui vous arrive tous les
deux vous n'avez pas l'air très en forme
6 6 6 mois ça va très très bien c'est ce
maladroit de casimir qui passe son temps
à se piquer les doigts avec ses six mois
ou pas du tout ce j'ai fait exprès de me
piquer pourra faire rire cet idiot de
léonard qui lui s'est réellement coupée
voilà bien la femme la plus incroyable
que jamais entendu
cette fable on pourrait peut-être
l'appeler le casimir us et le renard
quoi ben moi je ne veux pas être associé
à son mentor de l'onu mais si tu crois
que ça me plairait couillard à nos fins
attention mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça ah ça c'est pas un jeu des fables de
la fontaine
c'est un jeu comme à tous offert
monsieur du soir d'accord voilà je
t'explique quasi chaque dessin
représente une fable et il ya des
personnages correspondant qu'il faut
découper et placé dans le décor d'accord
de vous n'avez pas encore commencé enfin
pas si nous sommes en train de finir de
découper les personnages et j'ai une
idée je vais aller chercher les enfants
pour l'heure que vous continuez de
préparer le je voulais bien bien sûr
parfait comme ça ça me changera de ce
masque kahn a
écouté arrêté un petit peu avec et je
vais chercher les enfants trop soit vous
vous calmez
[ __ ] t'es
[Musique]
les enfants nous allons jouer au jeu des
fables de la fontaine
à votre avis quels sont les animaux qui
vont dans ce décor
le renard et il corrobore la région les
revoilà non oui c'est léonard le renard
alors voilà le corbeau et le renard bras
et il ya tant le fromage vous connaissez
la morale de cette fable
tout flatteur vit au dépend
s'il est bien entré m'a sans doute
qu'elle et ses décors ou très très joli
collier fait des tortues à votre avis on
sait qu'ils gagnent là et voilà le
lierse et la tortue qui a gagné oui
c'est ça alors voilà la tortue
et le lièvre de se reposer quelle est la
morale loin rien ne sert de courir il
faut partir à pourrir à point j'espère
que chez eux nos amis cherchent aussi il
trouve les bonnes réponses regardez ce
magnifique paysage dans le fond il ya un
berger et son troupeau de moutons à
votre avis le moucheron le mouton c'est
l'agneau
le loup et le loup et l'agneau vous
aviez trouvé chez vous ohlala louis
disaro et voilà l'agneau sûr qu'il avait
rien trouvé huit agneaux ont valu d'être
ici le loup si le yen vous connaissez la
mort à la wii qu'est ce que c'est la
raison est la meilleure parfait tu ne
connaissais la désigne un or que c'est
beau ce
qu'est ce que ça peut bien être quelles
sont les incidences la cigale et la
fourmi zh les voici
là
comme ceci vous connaissez la morale
vous savez ce que la presse que la
cigale dit à la fourmi à la fin de la
femme et lui dit vous chantiez j'en suis
fort thèse et bien non
le lion et lormont et laura alors
d'améliorer
ici la présence il est a u le lion est
pris dans les lois ici
c'est le rac à ronger le filet quelle
est la morale de cette fable de la
fontaine d'un plus petit que soi la
science et longueur de temps font plus
que force ni que rage on a toujours
besoin d'un plus petit que soi je trouve
que monsieur du snop s'est vraiment pas
manquer de bulles tous les deux nous on
repart au jardin les enfants en voir
leonard avoir casimir allons-y les
enfants voir alors je vais au jardin
amusez vous bien elle est venue
tu as vu ce que j'ai vu on fait tous
notre salle ou même pas profiter sans
nous et tout ça c'est de ta faute aussi
à ce que n'avait pas demandé à françois
de faire venir les en face aux aces
sincères mieux commencer l'année les
autres est de masques de carnaval et tu
dis que c'est de ma faute bravo mais
c'est toi qui m'a traitée de masques de
carnaval et le casimir us le plus
menteur depuis sept millions d'années
alors ça alors et toi tu te le renard le
le plus absurde et le plus stupide que
je n'ai jamais pu tuer pour quoi et
contenus à un hypocrite actu ne dit plus
un mot banane écrasée mot non plus ne
dit plus un mot ça tombe gras bien très
bien
finir cet imbécile de kazemi
n'aura coûté non si vous continuez à
vous dire les insultes mais c'est moi
qui vais m'énerver 1 mais enfin c'est
son renard qui m'a traitée de masques de
carnaval à séquelles émirats c'est assez
tutu bien plus idiot que léonard pour
toi et toi tu traites tu traites casimir
d'imbéciles mais que plus jamais simca
lui de le faire
parfaitement vous osé traiter d'imbécile
mon ami quasi muet moi je ne vous
permets pas traiter mon ami leonard
d'idiot
pouvoir tiendra non plus sortis
puisque vous le prenez comme ça je m'en
vais
mon brave les eaux là enfin
[Musique]